acknowledging that's the case here in
this but men haven't changed just
because the social parameters have
changed but the thing is the social the
social parameters have changed to
appease women yeah and so so but men
have remained the same they they want
the same things women have changed no
but as I said the social parameters have
changed so the social parameters have
for men have changed and the social
parameters for women have changed what
do you mean what do you define social
parameters so for example
materialistically men are supposed to
still provide be able to provide at a
higher rate and to faster rate from a
younger age this is the social parameter
change it's not realistic it is set up
by women I agree but with the women with
the ladies now a lot of us we have a
materialistic approach to how we view
men and when they can't provide that we
get upset we don't actually look at like
what you said the characteristics the
moralistic values we don't look at
actually when I look at this man do I
see family because a lot of people
they're they're they want uh Financial
benefits but they don't actually want
family what doesn't that make women the
problem then yeah it is because men are
the same like if anything more is
expected of man is less is given to them
because
I think that um we're getting married a
lot later in life and that's you know
part of it so like for example maybe 50
years ago getting married at age 16 to
18 might not have been a big deal
whereas now whether when a a young woman
wants to get married at 21 it's like are
you ready for this you know have you
finished uni yeah have you traveled
there's there's so much that women are
doing that they weren't doing 50 years
ago that they're doing now and it's it's
affecting that the age that people get
married so doesn't it make women the
problem
I never said women
I'm surprised when we're younger oh yeah
yeah before 40. and I'm curious I
haven't heard much from you what do you
think because I don't agree okay
tell me why tell me why because I'm
young isn't it so I'm just thinking when
I was younger women were always the one
um more involved in the relationships
men were always the one cheating
cheating the woman wrong so that now I'm
21. all of us are tired at the age of
20. why did you pick them
um right if you if you if you have women
hate being cheated on why'd you pick the
ones that cheat girls no you know early
on that they're going to cheat on you
you know you know damn well you know you
know you know you know damn well you
know damn well that that guy is capable
of cheating so how that's how is that on
him when you picked him do you know what
after I finished with the guys that she
I was not letting me go to a nice guy
even though you're but now you're a
leftover for him oh but I was only like
18 so yeah look at I'm not saying I'm
just saying that's how men view it 18.
yeah I mean I don't I don't know I'm not
gonna ask like what I'm just saying like
I'm saying this is common so so you're
young but I'm saying this is common
where girls will go through the bad boys
and the cheaters until they're 27 28 and
then come to the nice guys who they've
been rejecting the last decade right and
saying take me oh I'm ready for you and
they're like well now your Chad's
leftovers
and I hate that but it's like how is
that on them when we pick them because
one out of three men are either virgins
or haven't had sex in the last year so
there's a lot of men that won't cheat on
you you just don't want them
or go to go to you guys don't have time
do you guys have Taco Bell here you do
yeah go to go to Taco Bell ask the guy
out behind the counter I bet you he
won't cheat on you come on don't do that
go ask him out don't do that
you know how we're talking about the
whole team don't be for like back in the
day there was no social media like they
were writing letters everyone's covered
up from head to toe I feel like because
now there's more Temptation even for the
guys because women because yeah because
women got worse yeah because because
when men will do anything to get laid
okay literally literally anything so if
if we require marriage to get laid we
would all be married
um if we if we required a fancy date so
our values of lesson that's what you're
saying I would say women have thrown it
at them yeah like we're less valuable to
men because men are the same can we ask
the men that what's valuable to them
that would be yeah go ahead go ahead
like what do you mean like what what
does value mean to you in a woman
uh femininity uh submission
um being my piece
yeah that's it you know I would say
literally the same stuff as them but I
literally the same um being feminine
peace of mind
um being able to look at yourself as
well and have self-development like be
able to actually say yeah accountability
yeah you know what I mean being able to
have a conversation about stuff like if
there's an issue which some a lot of
people can't do to be honest so also
question do you guys value purity
what'd you guys would you guys rather
have cyber girl that slept with 100 guys
or one guy
I have a girl that slept with 10 guys or
50. okay okay so you value Purity yeah
yeah definitely yeah yeah same thing
yeah yeah okay what about you same as me
Blair you know what's crazy
um that you're talking about period I
went into someone's Tick Tock live but
it's about purity and she was talking
about Andrew Tate and you know he said
the same kind of thing yeah with girls
sleeping with loads of people and they
go sleeping with less
um and she said well I don't really care
what guys think I'll sleep with whoever
I want and as much people as I want
there's nothing you could do about it in
my head I just thought this is the
problem because I don't know if there's
like something I'm not mad but they will
still get laughed so yeah but no I don't
agree with it I agree with that I think
that's going to be tapped but that's
crazy but but those kind of girls but
those kind of girls I feel like I I
strongly disagree it's mad because you
get like let's say I've seen good guys
that will go for that and I'm just
saying like what I'll tell you why
they're the nice guys picking up the
leftovers and the problem is those girls
don't respect him because they actually
want the dude that cheated whenever
whenever a girl whenever a girl has a
guy that she always complains about
that's who she loved the most
it's not it's not the one that she
doesn't really talk about he said he was
such a good boyfriend he said she didn't
like him you're laughing you know it's
true
and so those guys picked them up at 30
and then they'll still cheat with the
the guy they really wanted or wish they
were with him you know what dumb fool
that's why that's why like virgins
should be preferred like if you if
you've slept with one person and you get
married what is your chance of a happy
marriage do you think
but then do you know what I find Crazy
that you also get the guys that complain
that all my day she didn't know what she
was doing in bed and then now he started
cheating five years down the line
because she's so dead and also no wait
no way no way no I've heard the guy say
we actually weren't sexually compatible
that's the reason why because he was
probably too much of a freak most girls
can't have good sex seriously most girls
are not good at six how did you know
uh-huh
no honestly most girls just take wood
let's be real like but if it's your
partner would you not teach them and
would you not
would you like not like growth like as
in you're teaching her what you like
she's teaching you what she likes of
course it's contextual
um I don't think you can be the partner
and not expect her to lack certain
things but then that's what I'm saying
certain guys they're just overly freaky
because most men are very simple to
please just block them it's true but
guys would prefer a girl they could
teach yeah versus because if she's
coming in a freak she's like where did
you learn that from